4 | 1+2+4+8+16+32+... = -1
Off 1. Il y a 4 ans, Minute Physics stupéfia
le web avec un calcul renversant. Après quelques
manipulations anodines, il conclut que 1+2+4+8+16+32+...
= -1.
OK. Ce sont des jolis calculs... Mais c’est
faux, hein. C’est clairement faux... Non
?
En fait, ce n’est pas si faux. Le truc,
c’est que l’infini est bien plus étrange
que le fini. J’espère que vous en avez
déjà eu un premier aperçu dans les épisodes
précédents. Et bien aujourd’hui, on va
plonger en plein dedans ! Mais avant d’en
venir à la somme spectaculaire de Minute
Physics, revenons-en à la première somme
infinie que l’on a croisée sur Science4All.
Dans le tout premier épisode de Science4All,
je vous ai dit que 4-4/3+⅘-4/7+... = π,
et dans l’épisode 2, je vous ai dit que
ceci voulait dire que plus on rajoute de termes,
plus la somme se rapproche de π.
Tout va bien ? Accrochez-vous à votre chaise
maintenant. Tout ce que l’on va faire, c’est
modifier l’ordre de la sommation. Et bien,
juste en changeant l’ordre de la sommation,
j’obtiens 4-4/3-4/7-4/11-4/15+4/5-4/19 = nombre
d’or !
GRIMACES SILENCIEUSES
Pourquoi le nombre d’or ? Est-ce qu’il
y a là une connection magique et inattendue
entre π et le nombre d’or ? Pas vraiment.
En fait j’ai choisi l’ordre de sommation
précisément pour que la somme fasse le nombre
d’or, tout ça pour vous rappeler que MicMaths
a fait une super vidéo à ce sujet… Mais,
en fait, peu importe le nombre que vous me
suggérez, je peux trouver un ordre de sommation
qui fera que la somme sera égale à ce nombre
!
GRIMACES SILENCIEUSES
Le truc avec cette somme, c’est qu’elle
contient des termes positifs et des termes
négatifs, et si j’ajoute uniquement les
termes positifs, j’obtiens la somme 4+⅘+4/9+4/13+...
qui est plus grande que 1+½+⅓+¼+... On
reconnaît là la somme harmonique, dont on
a prouvé dans l’épisode 3 qu’elle était
infinie. De façon similaire, si j’ajoute
uniquement les termes négatifs, j’obtiens
une somme -(4/3+4/7+4/11+...) < -(1+½+⅓+...),
qui est infiniment négative. Du coup, on
dit que la somme infinie 4-4/3+⅘-4/7+...
est semi-convergente, par opposition aux sommes
absolument convergentes. Et ça, ça lui confère
des propriétés déroutantes !
Off 2. Comme le fait qu’en changeant l’ordre
de sommation, je peux la faire égaler le
nombre d’or. Pour cela, je vais d’abord
mettre les termes positifs dans une colonne
et les termes négatifs dans une autre colonne.
Maintenant, si la somme des premiers termes
est jusque là inférieure au nombre d’or,
j’ajoute le plus grand nombre positif de
ma colonne de nombres positifs. À l’inverse,
si la somme partielle est supérieure au nombre
d’or, j’ajoute le nombre le plus négatif
encore dans sa colonne. Et ainsi de suite,
jusqu’à l’infini… On peut alors prouver,
et ce que j’ai fait dans cette vidéo de
Wandida, que la somme infinie sera alors exactement
égale au nombre d’or.
C’est ce que l’on appelle le théorème
de réarrangement de Riemann. Ce théorème
stupéfiant souligne une différence majeure
entre les sommes finies et les sommes infinies.
Alors que l’ordre de sommation n’a aucune
importance pour les sommes finies, par exemple
1+2=2+1, l’ordre de la sommation peut complètement
changer la valeur des sommes infinies ! Les
sommes infinies ne sont, en général, ni
associatives, ni commutatives.
Off 3. Voici un autre exemple de cette bizarrerie.
En 1655, John Wallis prouva l’égalité
π/2 = 2/1 * ⅔ * 4/3 * ⅘ * 6/5 * ... ≈ 1,57….
En réarrangeant les termes, on voit que l’on
peut réécrire la multiplication infinie
en (⅔)^2*(⅘)^2*(6/7)^2*..., qui est un
produit de termes tous inférieurs à 1, et
ne peut donc pas valoir 1,57 ! Encore une
fois, juste en changeant l’ordre des opérations,
on a complètement changé le résultat !
Et cette bizarrerie a amené bien des mathématiciens
à rejeter l’infini. Mais je pense qu’il
s’agirait d’une mauvaise raison de rejeter
l’infini. Tout ce que ça veut dire, c’est
qu’il faut être bien plus attentif aux
détails, et qu’il faut ne pas trop faire
confiance à notre intuition naïve, lorsque
l’on doit se frotter à l’infini. En fait,
si on prend suffisamment de précautions,
on peut même donner un sens à des sommes
divergentes comme la somme de Minute Physics
!
Revenons-en donc au calcul de Minute Physics.
La première chose à dire, c’est qu’il
ne faut pas faire ça à l’école. Sérieusement.
Jouer avec les sommes divergentes, c’est
un peu comme jouer avec le feu. Si vous faites
ça bien, vous pouvez en faire des trucs super
jolis, voire des trucs utiles. Mais si vous
ne savez pas ce que vous faites, non seulement
vous risquez de vous brûler au googolième
degré, vous risquez aussi de mettre feu à
tous ceux qui vous entourent. Bref, faites
attention si vous jouez avec les sommes divergentes
chez vous. Et, par pitié, ne faites pas ça
à l’école !
Autre chose avant de vraiment plonger dans
le coeur du problème. Il est utile de considérer
que le calcul de Minute Physics correspond
à une “supersomme“ plutôt qu’à une
somme classique. Et ça, ça veut dire qu’il
y a des choses qu’on a le droit de faire
avec les sommes, mais qu’on n’a pas le
droit de faire avec les supersommes. Par exemple,
changer l’ordre de sommation peut affecter
la valeur d’une supersomme, et la supersomme
de nombres tous positifs peut être négative.
Okay ! On peut y aller ! Le calcul de Minute
Physics repose sur trois propriétés fondamentales
de la supersomme qu’il effectue.
La première est la linéarité. Ça veut
dire que si on ajoute les termes respectifs
de deux supersommes, on obtient une valeur
qui est la somme des deux supersommes. Donc
si x est la valeur de la supersomme de Minute
Physics, alors 2x = x+x = (1+2+4+8+16+...)
+ (1+2+4+8+16+...) = 2+4+8+16+32+... Rien
de choquant a priori, hein ?
La deuxième propriété est la stabilité.
Ça veut dire que si on insère un 0 à une
supersomme, alors on n’affecte pas sa valeur.
Du coup, 2x = 2+4+8+16+32+... est égal à
0+2+4+8+16+32+... Ça peut paraître tellement
évident que vous vous demandez pourquoi j’en
parle. Et bien, cette propriété est, à
mon sens, ce qu’il y a de plus controversé
dans cette vidéo !
En combinant à nouveau linéarité et stabilité,
on obtient alors x=2x-x = (0+2+4+8+16+...)
- (1+2+4+8+16) = (-1)+0+0+....
Enfin, la troisième propriété est la régularité.
Elle dit que la supersomme d’une somme infinie
convergente doit être égale à sa somme.
En particulier, la somme infinie (-1)+0+0+....
est convergente, et converge vers -1. Du coup,
sa supersomme doit aussi valoir -1.
On obtient enfin le résultat de Minute Physics,
dans sa version plus formelle : Toute supersomme
linéaire, stable et régulière des puissances
de 2 est égale à -1.
Oui, c’est super bizarre. Mais n’oubliez
pas que la seule raison pour laquelle c’est
super bizarre, c’est parce que notre intuition
nous vient des exemples finis auxquels notre
quotidien nous a habitués. Mais l’infini
n’est pas qu’une simple extrapolation
de ce que nous savons être vrai dans le cas
fini. L’infini est infiniment plus étrange
que le fini…
Ceci étant dit, le calcul de Minute Physics
peut vous rester en travers de la gorge, et
vous pourriez vouloir rejeter la linéairité
ou la stabilité des supersommes. Du coup,
je vous propose un petit bouquet final, à
savoir un cadre dans lequel la véracité
du résultat de Minute Physics est indiscutable.
Off 4. Écrivons la somme de Minute Physics
en base 2. En base 2, il n’y a que deux
chiffres, le 0 et le 1. Du coup, les premiers
nombres en base 2 s’écrivent 0, 1, 10,
11, 100, 101, 110, 111, 1000 et ainsi de suite.
Je vous invite à aller en savoir plus sur
la base 2 avec cette vidéo de Wandida. En
particulier, 1 s’écrit 1, 2 s’écrit
10, 4 s’écrit 100, 8 s’écrit 1000, et
ainsi de suite. Du coup, la somme de Minute
Physics en base 2 s’écrit 1+10+100+1000+...
et ainsi de suite à l’infini. Combien ça
fait ? Très clairement, ça fait ….11111,
avec une infinité de 1 à gauche. Sauf que
bien sûr, ce nombre n’est pas un nombre
usuel. On l’appelle un nombre 2-adique,
notamment parce qu’on l’a obtenu en travaillant
en base 2.
Plus généralement, ces nombres dits p-adiques
peuvent sembler être une absurdité ou une
masturbation intellectuelle. Oui, clairement,
c’est une bonne masturbation intellectuelle.
Mais le plus surprenant, c’est qu’ils
ont des vrais applications et nous permettent
notamment de bien mieux comprendre les nombres
entiers auxquels on est habitués. Ainsi,
ils ont été utilisés par Andrew Wiles pour
prouver le dernier théorème de Fermat !
Off 5. Revenons-en au calcul. Ajoutons 1 au
nombre de Minute Physics. On doit alors poser
1+....111. Ajoutons les unités. On obtient
1+1, qui fait 2, ce qui, en base 2, s’écrit
10. On doit donc poser le 0 et retenir le
1. On doit alors à nouveau ajouter 1 et 1,
qui fait 10. On pose le 0 et on retient le
1… et ainsi de suite à l’infini. Si bien
que 1+ le nombre de Minute Physics fait une
suite infinie de 0… qui n’est autre que
0 ! Du coup, 1+ le nombre de Minute Physics
fait 0 : le nombre de Minute Physics vaut
donc -1 !
Je sais que ce résultat a l’air complètement
fou. Mais une autre façon de le comprendre,
c’est que le nombre 2-adique de Minute Physics
est un nombre “limite” quand on le regarde
modulo 2, puis modulo 4, puis modulo 8, et
ainsi de suite pour toutes les puissances
de 2. Après tout l’égalité 1+2+4+8+16+...
= -1 est vraie modulo 2, 4, 8, 16… et ainsi
de suite. Intuitivement, elle reste vraie
si on considère une classe “limite” qui
contient toute les classes modulo une puissance
de 2. Cette limite, c’est la classe des
nombres 2-adiques.
Bref. Tout ça pour dire que si
on cherche à comprendre les choses de la
bonne manière, le résultat de Minute Physics
devient
non seulement vrai, mais il est même profond
! Et révèle une partie de l’étrangeté
de l’infini...